juli ist verantwortlich für die teuerste
ausstellung der fondation beyeler 7
millionen franken kostet sie fast vier
jahre hat ihre planung gedauert nun
zeigt sie das früher eher unbekannte
werk picassos zuerst figuren zerlegt
kubistische picasso aber was aber die
umstellung zeit ist das dass es eine
vorgeschichte
diese vorgeschichte beginnt der blauen
periode den kurator beeindruckt wie
picasso ab 1901 seinen ersten eigenen
stil entwickelt zu sehen bekommen wir
hier aus sicherheitsgründen aber bloß
eine maggette als platzhalter für das
schlüsselwerk ich mich habe ich sage
dass es erste großformatige meisterwerke
von picasso ist es ist zusammenfassend
bild wo man all die große thema erkennen
ihn damals beschäftigt arbeitet in dem
bild wieder ein sitz tod von einem
freund zur carlos katar das feuer
[Musik]
carlos gastgebers hier wie im picasso
auf dem totenbett hatte sich wegen einer
unglücklichen liebe erschossen
lavik sieht man links
die stehen die männliche figur darf sich
zum kaffee massiv aber anhand von
skizzen picassos bin ich selber ein bild
für die porträtieren eigentlich ein
selbstporträt plante und das praktisch
am schluss noch mal modifiziert und hat
praktisch muss dann noch eine hommage an
die verstorbene freund machte die
emotionen dass sein keller kommt zur
stippvisite
der direktor der fondation beyeler
begutachtet den heilungsprozess
die blaue periode steht für eine
melancholische phase im ernsten und
nachdenklichen selbstporträt von 1901
deutlich spürbar
tatsächlich zeigt die misere stück
wieder anziehen japan eigene haben
erfahrt es ist ein großer armut lag dass
er zieht wo aus sie will dass ich da die
blaue bilder nicht so gut verkaufen
selbstbewusst war picasso trotzdem der
rötliche bad verweist auf vincent van
gogh mit dem er sich anscheinend
vergleicht jeder raum der gesamten
ausstellungsfläche von über 2.300
quadratmetern wird bespielt am modell im
maßstab eins zu zwanzig testete profi
die hämmer
so habe das alles muss papieren und
experimentieren so dass der band
original and the magic ist ganz klar ist
wir alles die spioniert ist ja alles
sanken und stoßen
zur ausstellung gehört auch die rosa
periode ab 1904 statt grün und blau
dominieren nun rottöne gut zu erkennen
in akrobatischen alica von 1905 das werk
mit bezug auf einen zirkus der damals in
paris gastiert
akrobaten und harlekine inspirierenden
maler sehr
es sind als identifikationsfigur von
kunststoff sie verkörpere frehner stück
wieder auf ihren bürgerlichen anstand
die gesellschaft man sagt muss man sagen
das künstlerduo man sich für den kurator
interessant wie kassow blüht nun auf er
entdeckt die frau als inspirationsquelle
kurze zeit trofana und olivier kann
erklären
moralisch gesehen in deinem
künstlermilieu sich bewegt hat und sehr
stand hier herrscht die langjährigen
lebenspartnerin vom gas worten und sind
herrschte große hammer wird sage was
hier bald hängen wird sind die ersten
verkaufserfolge picassos sie stammen aus
der rosa periode die zudem eine
entscheidende reise lieb ihren ehen mit
sich bringt körper spielfigur
afghanisches gesicht und das wird den
kubismus natürlich ein ganz wichtiges
thema bliebe die blaue und die rosa
periode enden 1906 das teuerste gemälde
aus dieser zeit ist heute 200 millionen
franken wert doch war vw fahrer nicht
welches es ist